what do you say that filmmakers who are
looking to promote at the festival let's
say they're planning to attend or
postcards really effective I mean they
just in different places I've gone to
they're in the lobby you are there in
front of where the screening is do you
think people actually pick them up that
helps I know sometimes you be surprised
there's a lot of there's not folks that
like that that seem to to go to
screenings and attend anything and just
like to like they keep everything like
to take all these postcards like this I
don't know we could post card poker on
like this no isn't they sound like
they're in the bag saying they want a
goodie bag there all these they love
taking postcards but yeah so there's
that but outside of that I mean they're
good it's definitely a good thing you
you need to have a presence when I have
something out there is it something
that's gonna you know get you that that
agent or that deal down I'm at you we
can't obviously say I couldn't say that
you know I mean no I wouldn't think so
it's in time if they saw your film get
information from that then I guess yet
so it's you know you know with the
screening someone that's really
important you know whether it's
producers my agent someone you want to
see the film come out can't you know I
can't talk to you you just busy or you
know you're running around or everyone's
talking about the screening they don't
get to you or something you know you
want your stuff out there the
information it's part the visibility of
the festival that's very important but
you know with that said yeah I feel like
it's not it's not a it's not like
actually imperative and it's not
something that you know if I mean like
if people yeah I think some people they
notice consumer will probably don't but
it's it's at least some visibility
doesn't hurt to have your stuff out
there I feel it's important to have
postcards and information out there and
the more you're like at the fest
aggressive chatter from all your stuff
the better so I gets to go back to it if
you put postcards on never show up so
that's all we can just go to your movie
I say no if you have your postcard out
there where your they're passing people
or you know people hey what about you we
will grab this poster here you go and if
you did then yes I mean it's it's people
remember that its visibility it's a good
it's a good catchy postcard whether it's
the image of the film or it's a cool
poster or whatever that stuff helps you
know and if you're getting it out there
and every date sometimes in the
screening you know people will will will
come into your film I mean the festival
was grown at the point now where it's
more engaged people want to enjoy those
take it in and see other films to get to
know other filmmakers go see their stuff
so there's a supportive thing that goes
on you meet it opening night and you
just discuss a lot of stuff and then you
go I won't see your film also your film
you share that that happens so it's yeah
so that is good to have this stuff out
there but uh there's other ways to
promote and stuff and that may be even
better than that of course but it
doesn't hurt to have you know I think
it's definitely good to have postcards
the festival one but to go back to it
gonna be there you know drop your stuff
off and never be there yeah no that
doesn't definitely do the job
you